hey guys how's it going it's Justine
today we're going to be going through my
gear bag this is updated for the new
MacBook Pro with touch bar because I
definitely needed a few extra cables and
another additional hard drive here's the
bag that I decided to go with this is a
really cool incase bag this definitely
doesn't have enough room if I'm bringing
a drone or external hard drives or
multiple cameras this is basically a
perfect setup for computer one hard
drive one camera a few lenses and all of
the cords and cables that I'm going to
need to get the job done so let's open
this up and go through and I'll show you
guys what I have yep so inside this
pocket this is a nice secret little
compartment that I like to hide some USB
C cables and the USB C power brick I do
have two USB C cables because I've a
feeling good I'm either going to lose
one or somebody at one point in time is
going to need one and I'll have an extra
that they can borrow over here in this
pocket
I've got snapchat spectacles I've been
super obsessed with these things and I
love having sort of a dedicated place
for them in my bag so moving right along
to our main pouch here star of the show
our macbook pro there's a nice little
blind spot right here that I can put him
so he's protected so this bag varies
depending upon which camera I have
currently this is set up for the EOS m5
I have the
cannon microphone I've got an extra lens
and I also have an extra battery and a
charger and some lens caps so this is
the camera that that bag was set up for
if I'm using a camera I don't usually
put it in this bag I like to have it
with me at all times and no matter where
I'm going or what I'm doing I almost
always have this with me this is the
canon g7x it's such a perfect vlogging
camera because it just works you push
the button and you're ready to go never
leave home without your Nintendo 3ds
this is my USBC portable hard drive this
is the Porsche design LaCie it's not a
solid state so I have to be super
careful when I'm traveling with it and
it looks good I also always have an
extra movie with me no matter what's
also a very nice thing about this one is
granted it's not USB see but it does
have a micro cable too so if you need to
charge something like a Samsung or
anything that has a micro USB this is
also built into it this is the cable bag
of do
Oh God you always want to carry a
charging brick with you extra battery
for my g7x this is the USB c5 and one
that I put you are female basically I
can we call these cords at home and as
long as I have this I'll be good to go
USB C to lightning snapchat case charger
USB C to basic USB USB C to USB port USB
C to USB C micro USB another USB C to
basic USB another mini USB also this
dongle very important for my iPhone 7
Apple watch charger extra SD card GoPro
battery emergency tripod emergency
dongle headphones and other emergency
micro USB this is the USB charger for
3ds in case of emergencies sony a7s
battery another Mophie just in case and
another micro USB cable as i said
earlier i have separate bags made up for
whatever camera i'm gonna have in here
this is my sony a7s bag i'm able to have
a microphone a lens and the body all in
one so if i'm not using this camera then
this one goes inside and if it happens
to be a drone day here's my Mavic this
is the Mavic bag inside here i full
batteries the drone controller car
charger regular charger this is my most
favorite and prized possession ever if
by some crazy emergency i need to take
all of these cameras with me this is an
amazon basics DSLR backpack this thing
is incredible you can hold so much in
here i can hold all those cords and
cables all in here it also has extra
places to put all kinds of things place
to put your laptop right here it's also
got these nice little side pockets cuz i
always like to have water so you can put
the water here which keeps it separate
from your electronics this little side
pocket you can put a tripod and these
will let you strap it in so it doesn't
move around well thank you guys so much
for watching this video i hope that you
enjoyed it if there's anything that you
think that i'm missing from my bag let
me know in the comments below and i'll
put a link in the description to
everything that i talked about so you
guys could know what exactly it is that
I was talking about also let me know if
there's any videos that you guys would
like me to make in the future or if you
have any questions about any of my
setups or anything that I do that might
seem a little strange feel free to leave
those also in the comments I'll see you
guys in the next video
bye oh and it's a linear mode - oh it's
rolling off
that's how using my car